let's check out the first dad these are  pretty interesting for sale certified  pre-owned 2014 man-bun seeking Wilson AK  seeking a date for st. Patrick's Day it  is tonight right  [Applause]  look at this it says fake ID service  doesn't work at bars but can get you  into any TV taping  oh look at this one ah this is sweet for  sale t there's a next one VIP pass come  visit me on the set of my Disney Channel  show it's a matter of Zach  like this one out hire me I have a face  that was born to deliver high school  sports highlights in small-to-medium  news markets and finally special offer  by one elementary school teacher get one  free  can't buy you know Neji school  you